a chocolate teapot an ashtray on a
motorbike the underwater hairdryer some
inventions are non-starters good ideas
on the other hand are a little harder to
come by
but sometimes having a brilliant idea
isn't enough just ask Douglas Engelbart
you've probably never heard of Douglas
Engelbart you're more likely to have
heard of Steve Jobs here's why in 1960
the Stanford Research Institute
Engelbart a student of Electrical
Engineering noted that the way people
were interacting with their new
computers was inefficient a combination
of chunky keyboards and clunky joysticks
Engelbart thought he could do better his
solution to this was a device that
controlled an on-screen cursor named the
bug via two perpendicular wheels from
afar and it was a brilliant idea
in 1966 NASA trial legolas invention and
found it one of their more efficient
pieces of technology two years later
alongside his fellow inventor Bill
English Douglas showcased something
called the mouse to a 1,000 strong San
Francisco crowd in what became known
within industry circles as the mother of
all demos Engelbart and English had a
smash hit on their hands their Mouse was
the next big thing only it wasn't five
years later
Engelbert lost his funding and many key
members of his team including Bill
English left Stanford to work the Xerox
and in 1979 a man you may have heard of
offered Xerox shares in his company in
exchange for eyes on their Research
Center that man was Steve Jobs the
company was Apple and the Research
Center yielded the mouse jobs loved the
idea so much that legend has it he had a
team of engineers immediately stop what
they were working on in order to rebuild
streamline and ultimately relaunch the
mouse as an apple product the Stanford
Research Institute owned the original
patents meaning Engelbart never saw any
of the profit from future sales of these
mice Hinkle Bart's thinking was ahead of
his time but sometimes a good idea just
needs someone like Jobs with the force
of personality to see it through
somebody with the ability to see beyond
was directly in front of them those who
can dream a little
take Stephanie colic for example here it
was a talented chemist with a passion
for fabrics and textiles who through her
research into synthetic fibers
discovered a solution stronger than
steel but as light as fiberglass we call
her invention Kevlar and today it
appears in tires our gloves bulletproof
vest spacesuits from spacecraft but when
Stephanie first developed this
crystallized cloudy liquid colleagues
refused to spin it for her fearing it
would clog up their machines it was 1965
when qualit was dreaming up her
super-strength fibers a decade earlier
filmmaker Morton huiling had dreamed of
creating an immersive sensorial
experience for cinema audience and so in
1957 he created the sensorama
a 3d video machine that let audiences
experience riding a motorbike via
vibrating seats and wind machines or
watch a belly dancer perform with cheap
perfume pumped into the auditorium high
league had grand ambitions and he
pitched his censer armor to Henry Ford
as a revolutionary show tool the future
was there for the taking only it wasn't
because nobody including Ford wanted to
buy it
the sensorama ended up beneath a
tarpaulin in high leagues back garden
Morton was undeterred three years after
the first sensor armor he patented the
telesphere mask a 3d video headset
viewed from today one can sketch a
direct path from Hilux masks to the
oculus rift and a virtual reality
industry that is expected to be worth
170 billion dollars by the year 2022
sadly though Morton Heilig will not be a
part of it
he died in 1997 before VR found an
audience in its current form no perfume
required high league like Engelbart
before him had the right idea at the
wrong time Wilson Greatbatch on the
other hand was exactly where he needed
to be and when Wilson wanted to listen
to and record the human heart he failed
spectacularly when attempting to record
the heart's electrical impulses Wilson
chose the wrong size resistor instead of
recording his machine started to give
out an electrical pulse of its own
Greatbatch was not listening to the
heart he was speaking to it Wilson
Greatbatch had just accidentally
invented the pacemaker
his mistake would save millions of lives
over the next 60 years and continues to
do so after hit tested out on a couple
of dogs suffice to say it worked great
batches company today still manufactures
90% of all pacemaker batteries made
worldwide the man himself lived to a
ripe old age his heart never missing a
beat in 92 years as Henry Ford himself
once mused failure is simply the
opportunity to begin again this time
more intelligently just a shame he never
bought that sensorama when he had the
chance thanks for watching don't forget
to subscribe and click the bail to
receive notifications for new videos see
you again soon